dude i'll tell you who usually bats a
thousand and just
struck out with the latest movie capone
with tom hardy
i've been oh no counting down the days
for this i
posted the trailer like i can't wait
[ __ ] yes take my money
i paid 9.99 last night got a [ __ ]
fresh hot meal
he's such a good actor he's so good this
movie
really is a complete waste of time and i
love tom hardy and i don't hate on
i'm not hitting on him it was it was the
premise
the whole so what it is it's his last
year so capone died of
a system crazy yeah and he had syphilis
for a long time
because he used to be a bouncer at a
brothel and slept with all the women
yeah he got syphilis forever
and how crazy this because of his ego he
didn't want
people to know he had it so he's like
off it's not that big of a deal
so he never got it he didn't want to he
didn't want to go and admit that he got
std wow
so he could be because of his ego so
this i don't even think they had a cure
back then
they had help they had things that would
help okay and then uh penicillin came
after world war ii correct yes
yes but they they had help they had
things that would definitely help and he
ignored all
i didn't know capone had that many scars
on his face yep what was that from
uh as a kid he got a fight wow but um so
the movie is the last year of his life
when he gets out of
alcatraz he gets out of prison because
his wife
uh was able to convince uh the
government that he's you know he's sick
yeah syphilis is going crazy
let him live his last years of his life
in florida so they're in palm
somewhere in florida he has this huge
mansion there he has no money they have
to sell the statues and stuff
but this the entire movie the the demise
of capone and it's him talking to and
this is true which they based off him
talking to
his old friends and just going crazy and
that's it
and that's it dude he shuts the bed
he's pissing the bed he's just crazy and
you're like what is this [ __ ] man
i got two hours into i'm like what am i
doing was it critically acclaimed with
the acting or is it just like
something you don't want to see if
somebody's going crazy
yeah yeah acting stuff really that sucks
i'm telling you don't waste your money
take it from your boy there's nothing i
love than a mafia movie i [ __ ] is it
on netflix i love
mafia nope you gotta pay for it dude
okay it's on amazon or it's on uh itunes
um you can get it there it is tough
it is very tough oh boy that the whole
capone stuff i love man he's such a
beast
you know you know so in the height of
his career if it was today he was worth
1.5 billion dollars at one point
goddamn crazy right yeah he ran some
[ __ ]
you know he's 240 pounds did you know
that capone was
real real fat fat was 540 pounds he's
short
wasn't missing any meals i love de
niro's uh capone and the untouchables
you ever see that movie the untouchables
uh i've seen parts of it when i was a
kid he's so he's like there is violence
on in chicago not by me
not by anybody i employ i'll tell you
why the outfit that's
what's called the outfit he's great in
it
you see him you see him crying and they
out during the opera he plays this
amazing
dichotomy well it doesn't look like him
at all but that's whatever dude yeah but
he's so good
you know you believe he's a [ __ ] you
believe he's a guy i think tom hardy but
it was a tough job because he was going
crazy it's like
i don't know it's a tough gig dude
tough [ __ ] game one thing tiger loves
to do with his dad is watch
rick and morty there's cussing in it
there's some stuff kids probably
shouldn't see but it's our thing yeah
so the new season sunday nights so it is
before bed he was pop i don't watch rick
and morty
the new one doesn't come out to way
later but we'll watch it tomorrow or
later this week
and he goes come on can i just watch one
i said you have 15 minutes you have 15
minutes then we're going to bed
so i put on the one where they're doing
the they're emulating the
oceans 11 where they're doing a heist
right and so he asked all his old
friends
to come in and so he like finds them
right and he's with morty
and more he's like who's that and then
he's like whatever and then all the
guests that they go you son of a [ __ ]
i'm man and it's like a high life going
you son of a [ __ ] i'm man
so then uh earlier in the day right i
always quote rick and morty early in the
day
for the f or the previous date joanna
goes hey i'ma have ceviche for the
fights when the family comes over and i
go you son of a [ __ ] i'm in
and i walked outside and got more a bike
do you see how you gotta do
so then we watch that episode and then
we're going back all right tt time for
the
time for bed and he looks and he goes
you son of a [ __ ] oh man that's it
they copy everything you do [ __ ] on me
i go
i could not stop laughing and i was like
dude you can't me
dude you can't i'm laughing so he knows
he's not in trouble oh dude you can only
say that word around papa
because only around power don't stay
around kids and these other parents only
around papa that's my son and i have a
deal where he can say anything he wants
around me yeah so when i'm when i'm i'm
driving him in the car he goes
he goes shut the [ __ ] up this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm like dude take it easy
it's like play time he's son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm like hey hey hey hey
calm down
he just can't wait to stop start saying
it you son of a [ __ ] oh man
he jumps in bed you son of a [ __ ] that
shows [ __ ]
i kept [ __ ] my son finally i was go
buckle up okay because i am i go
all right buckle up yes i am i go yeah i
know and i'm just saying
buckle up i am all right all right
buckle up and he's uh i am screaming
buckle up he goes i shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
look at that he looks dead oh my god
he looks like the guy from um
he looks like a guy from pirates of the
caribbean the skeleton that tells them
where to go and they use him as a
backpack
is that pirates of the caribbean or is
that is
what is he doing there is it just or is
that uh india is that
like he's not eating anything ugh
the weight cut is such a [ __ ]
what movie oh no you know what movie
that is
uh hellboy type in hellboy skeleton are
we hearing
anything from comments shut up is he
talking about fighting
shut the [ __ ] up you shut up i asked a
question
are we hearing anything about connor uh
he was talking shits and ideas
the uh dana says a they wanted to fight
on fight island
there he is there's connor that's spot
on
that's exactly who it is there he is use
the background to tell him where to go
you're good at tech
you're good at the best he has a gift
we need to get him on a bike on the
bottom there thick boy first team right
there yeah
how about sent in a group message you're
not on it a big deal
cat sent a group text of her uh mom for
mother's day
i'm a look and i'm a liking cat cat yeah
my mom's a looker hey
straight up let's take a no offense
smoke show
really yes yeah cause i posted up a
photo
from when i was a kid my mom was like 23
she just had me
yeah uh i think in the white tank top
she's hot as [ __ ]
uh here i'll text you yeah her mom is
i was like cat is that your mind i don't
know if his chin's mom or cat's mom no
offense
dad look at that i just texted you
okay yeah that's not awake for me dad
huh no
my dad has always had a rat tail a lot
of people say that he
has the same haircut as theo oh
but does he is it short on the sides
long it's just not as thick in the back
where it's long
so he has like a rat tail whereas theo
has like a full mullet mullet might be a
wig we don't know
we don't know but your dad's the real
thing all natural all right always
yeah cat's mom is a bona fide smoke show
i need to see a picture that's her
little cat too
yeah i'm the one in pink mom is cute
right oh jeez yeah that's my mom at my
age
what 24. look how cute you were a cat
that's a little big baby how old are you
there uh i think i'm about like
a year like under a year under you have
a strawberry in your hand
i think so i'm always i was always
eating so i would imagine
who's dora the explorer in the
background that's my cousin
uh marcia she she hates that photo every
time i post it
i have to crop her out because she hates
people
now everyone has it she's a cute little
girl
dude your mom is freaking gorgeous yeah
mom
mom is no joke i mean dude you don't
have a rat to not pull hoes
you know what i'm saying you're a rat
tail and you own it you're getting hoes
yeah my dad is actually 15 years older
than my mom too
how was your dad uh i have no idea he's
like that looks like he is
your dad looks like he knows how to he
knows his way around a rain stick i'll
put it that way
a rain
nothing to her has ever been said
oh my god he definitely has the most
wisdom around the
brain sticks nothing to her ever
um your mom's straight up bona fide dime
piece
you know you know if your mom's hot oh
yeah oh yeah absolutely but papa looks
like he's thick is he thick he could be
no
he's not thick at all he's like you
can't be in a club that you're not in
and say people are in it well here's the
thing
you're not even no i don't tell people
you don't know the request why is your
club so discriminatory what if you are a
thin boy
well you're thinking and you think at
heart you're in but you're not thick at
heart why don't you have a thin boy
offshoot like a branch out
why not that's not what we do dude we
don't specialize in that but i feel like
there would be guys who know what
we'll see how you do on the trails on
thursday you might post it i couldn't
listen to it because i
saw it too late at night i didn't want
to wake up anybody uh what's the video
posted are you singing
and you're like you guys won't like this
is it gay
i liked it i watched it it was just like
a funny post because i thought your post
is funny the brian's
what was ryan's the stairway well i said
that that that wasn't
but what i was doing was making a point
saving lives
in other words being out of shape i hope
people know i wasn't
serious about putting people in jail for
being fat what i was saying is that if
you use the criteria
if you use the criteria if you use
criteria saving lives diabetes kills
almost 80 000 americans
you put them in jail yeah i'm i'm joking
you can you can you can take things to
it if that's your criteria for
everything you can you can
justify any kind of behavior i hope that
wasn't lost
if it's a joke it's a joke let me see
yours jen let me find it real quick
oh it's right there so i'll just fast
forward the part that i thought was
funny
no let me see the whole thing it's the
long one
it's five minutes dude and we own the
own this footage we can the fans can see
it
all right cats in it too you guys are
all in it
oh really yeah i'm good i'm in a music
video i like to see my royalties
michael bolton you like the slower gems
i love michael bolton this is something
that's cold michael and passed away
no no no i could hardly believe it
when i
[Music]
had to heard and get it straight from
you
[Music]
said you were leaving someone spread
your heart away
wait
[Music]
[Music]
tell me one more
that's not easy
that is not easy
wow so i'll just fast forward this
that's very good
thank you i'm sorry
that's note perfect that's [ __ ] a
real isn't that a really hard song to
sing
it's tough on you physically yeah
people like to [ __ ] on michael bolton
he's no he's he's amazing yes people
shouldn't like a bullet oh they love
it meanwhile that guy's talented all
[Music]
right
am i supposed to carry on
that's great
[Music]
that's so funny
so that was it that's really good that's
very thank you that's really funny
well i'm drinking water oh before you
have some that daddy stopped drinking
at night because you know what happens
when he drinks wine daddy has a little
bit of tummy i told you that yesterday
at the
park got a little tummy and also i have
my face tends to hold water i look like
a roswell alien you know those roswell
aliens
looking like that or a floating dead
body in the river
take it easy i mean my face never been
more swollen either so
who am i to say the best is um the best
is i've been getting a lot of uh dms
about
starting my own business and people have
ideas that they want to go into business
those are always great
always good from rick and morty show
brennan up this is an idea and i
want to start an app show brandon up i'm
like hey guys i'm not
i'm not trying to not competing i'm not
that's not
the point but thank you show them up
dude start
certain leather belt it's always the
worst start leather belts i make them
out of my home
dude we put calen on the front of these
buckles you're gonna sell a million of
them
my profit's only 60 i'll share 40 that's
what i get
i'll share 40 with no hey no
you know who i love you just i just
listened to it uh the guy from uh dirty
jobs
mike rowe that guy is awesome how smart
is he his vocabulary
he is so impressive really oh my god he
must write
his that was good that was a good word
really really it was pretty good yeah
that was pretty good the way you said
that it was yeah
that was very good i never thought of
them that way yeah my i mean i watched
the show
religiously all the time but then we
hear him speak like oh my god
well he's he's one of those guys that's
smart for the right reasons like you
could talk to academics all day i
interview these
high level guys that i love i love
talking to them about that guy
um i love talking to those guys but it's
like it's like book smart you know and
that's that's important
obviously but a guy like mike rowe it's
like his smarts do come from something
else
physical like being down there with
these guys that work
literally the worst dirty jobs you can
imagine and finding out like what it is
that they know about the world you know
like what have they figured out
how is it that you can like literally be
cleaning up [ __ ] all day
like animal [ __ ] or human [ __ ] and still
find purpose in the world still find
happiness all that stuff
he's been around those people and i
think that that kind of like that's what
i
find when you try when you do stand up
as much as like i do or now you do yeah
you know one of the things that i know i
realized when i was always touring and
being around my audience where
sometimes a lot of times younger or
whatever but they were a lot of blue
collar
middle class as i kind of was like i
actually don't know any more than they
do
in a lot of ways i was talking to my
friend
and it happened with you talking it was
down at the pier
the man 60 years old came walking with a
briefcase
and uh well he's naked but he did have a
copy yeah conquering
not a cockroach it was around his balls
and his [ __ ] it was like that's like a
super
concrete i was walking like nothing was
it was just what you do
it's like like we were bothering him the
rule in san francisco is you can walk
around
completely naked with a [ __ ] or whatever
i don't know what that is what do you
you tie off at the base either way it's
important but if you
if you are in any way hard well now you
better get arrested now you got to put
something
did you see where we were you could walk
around with a flaccid penis
yeah no no no no no no no no
why wouldn't i give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift
it's a gift